let's begin here in the US on March 14
2020
there are 1678 confirmed kovat 19 cases
in the US that day according to the
World Health Organization that same day
Apple decides to close its stores across
the country
Apple is temporarily closing all of its
doors outside China a week later on
March 21st cases in the US have gone up
by over 800 percent and in that week
dozens and dozens of more retailers
closed including Nike Sephora IKEA and
the gap
we tracked hundreds of store closures
Global coronavirus case data and
official lockdown measures and found
that as the virus spread across the
world Apple has been one of the first to
close its stores specifically in the
United States in most instances Apple
shutdowns proved to be an early
indicator of the trajectory of
individual cases other retail closures
and government mandated lock downs one
piece that's really surprised me most
about the pen that make more broadly and
how Apple has behaved is the number of
companies that have either followed
their lead or are looking for
information from Apple now with States
coming out of lockdown Apple has
reopened and reclosed some stores some
news here from Apple that it's gonna
temporarily close some stores again here
Scott do to kovat 19 spikes that could
be a signal of what's ahead it's sort of
like the waffle house - the waffles see
the American restaurant chain changes
its menu based on how severe it thinks a
hurricane or storm may be closing only
when the damage is expected to be
extreme so is Apple the kovat equivalent
or is Apple just more nimble than other
retailers because of its business
strategy and 200 billion in the bank
Apple wasn't always ahead on store
shutdowns take its first closure and
sing doubt China on January 28th there
were five thousand nine hundred seventy
four confirmed kovat 19 cases in China
that day yet other stores like Starbucks
and the gap had closed some of its China
stores that same day or earlier within a
week of Apple's first closure kovat
cases in China had grown 307 percent
On February first Apple shut all 40-plus
of its mainland China locations john
emanuel Biondi is a principal at
Deloitte and works with some of the
world's top retailers we did not have
any idea at that point of time of what
was about to come the discussion we had
was related to the impact of co-head not
so much on the consumers and the market
in the United States but this disruption
from a supply chain standpoint by March
with the virus spreading far beyond
China Apple moved a lot faster more than
a week before the UK went into lockdown
on March 14th Apple closed its stores in
the country while others like Nike
Adidas and Starbucks stayed open for two
to six days longer meanwhile the rest of
Apple stores outside of China closed on
the 14th - including in the US where it
has 271 stores that's more than any
other country I would say that every
retailer who is in Asia looked at the
measures that were implemented in Asia
and say can i implement to what extent
can i implement some of the similar
measures in the united states in the US
only patagonia closed that same day over
the next week more than 50 major
retailers closed and then in May stores
began reopening and in June Apple hit
the brakes and reclosed some including
in Texas California and Florida in
Orlando specifically Apple reclosed its
store at the Florida Mall on June 26th
two weeks later cases in that County had
more than doubled still other retailers
in the area including
Nike and the spy remained open both
companies declined to comment so how
does Apple decide when and where to
close the company says it looks at the
following data on the county-level case
numbers positivity rates hospital ICU
and ventilator usage asymptomatic
testing and more if public info isn't
available the company says it calls
public health departments to request
data but why Apple why has the company
been quicker to close stores than others
it's not because Apple stores aren't
money makers but rather they're not
apples only way to make money and Apple
has the money to do it
Jean monster has been researching Apple
for nearly 20 years we estimate that
their physical stores are somewhere
between 8 and 10 percent of total
revenue in online is an additional 10 to
12 percent of total revenue monster and
other analysts predict that large parts
of the physical retail sales have
shifted to online during the second
quarter of 2020 which included the
months of January to March
Apple sold nearly 50 billion dollars
worth of products and CEO Tim Cook told
CNBC its online growth was off the
charts the bigger cost to Apple and
store closures in the March quarter
Apple paid out to its retail employees
about a hundred million dollars even
though they weren't actually in the
stores working in the June quarter that
number is going to be just under two
hundred million dollars and so keep in
mind brick-and-mortar retail business is
close to a thirty billion dollar year
annual business and so even though these
numbers are large they have the
framework to continue to support and pay
for employees throughout the the
pandemic Apple's free cash flow in the
March quarter was thirty point three
billion dollars even as its stores were
closing much of that came from online
sales that allowed it to pay its retail
staff despite its doors being shut and
Apple can continue to do so because it
has one of the biggest rainy day funds
and
business when you factor in its debt
Apple has a little over eighty billion
dollars of cash in the bank
compare that with Nikes eight billion or
Best Buy's nearly four billion Apple has
so much cash on hand that it could run
its operations for more than a year
without cutting its costs or selling a
single iPhone they have a lot of money
they have an ability to navigate this
unlike most companies and so I would
look for Apple to have more store
closings than other retailers who are
navigating a lot of the same information